thank you all very much our time is
shorter than I would like so we got to
move swiftly along we really have we've
all heard about the fiscal cliff facing
the federal government well that is
creating a fiscal cliff for the federal
government's historic role in paying for
a lot of transportation infrastructure
and it's not just a I'm gonna skip this
because you'll get all this as we go
through I'm going to lay out how this
really is affecting thing is it's an
opportunity to make a major paradigm
shift across the board in how we do this
stuff okay so first of all as you know
we've heard some other presentations
this weekend we have a completely
unsustainable the gut federal government
is insolvent it's not going to go away
for the rest of our lives and the lives
of many people younger than I this is
going to be the background condition
because it's going to take decades to
get out of this and we're now in a very
artificial environment with interest
rates close to zero you get back a
serious economists who works I've read
you get back to normal interest rates
probably within the decade interest on
this now enormous national debt is going
to be start getting up into ten fifteen
twenty percent of the federal budget and
that is going to squeeze out an awful
lot of things that we've taken for
granted the federal government does so
the sequester there isn't sequester they
only pushed it off March first the
sequester by law now unless Congress
changes the law kicks in cutting eight
percent round numbers of defense of
budget for the current year and about
six point nine percent of non-defense
discretionary budget not up not if
nothing at all about entitlements but
all the other stuff and that is going to
that that's the first i predict of many
such sequester's many such
across-the-board cuts we're going to be
seeing there will be no more general
fund government for all kinds of things
some people consider nice to have like
high-speed rail and so forth but
unlawful lot of other things too now
this be if the federal government's role
is reduced the states are going to have
to presumably do more but can they pick
up the slack and they invest more in
transportation truck well they all have
balance but
requirements but those are based on cash
accounting they go they're not generally
accepted accounting principles
accounting and so the budget conditions
of state governments is way far worse
than it looks like at the outset Richard
ravaged and paul volcker did this report
which is gotten almost no attention the
state budget crisis task force report
that really in stark terms outlines how
bad off thing the state government
budgets really are Medicaid expansion is
a huge looming threat they already have
massive pension overhangs that we've
heard talk about and they consistently
use budget gimmicks like Jerry Brown
does California disguise the true nature
of what the situation is so it's
difficult to the states are simply not
going to have money available to make up
for cutbacks in federal money so we have
this project underway now that we reused
the report in January that we decided to
do last September when we saw this
coming on a program for using this
taking advantage of Rama manuals never
let a crisis go to waste this is a major
crisis facing all of Transportation and
we are going to starting taking a clue a
cue from the sense and Bowles Commission
report which whose reports so far has
been ignored saying look infrastructure
really is important we may not be
investing wisely in it now but we need
more sound investment and so and Clinton
Clifton simpson-bowles Commission said
look the way to protect infrastructure
from these across-the-board cut backs is
to make it a hundred percent supported
by user fees so that the user fees are
not subject to across-the-board
government cutbacks and that we're
taking that to heart the current federal
role for all of these transportation
things is they have user taxes of a
different kind for each mode they put
the money into account for it as a
federal trust fund for that particular
mode and then the Congress appropriates
money out of that money each year plus
some general fund money usually and of
course you put all kinds of conditions
and strings attached to any federal
dollar one dollar or federal money
balloons your costs a way higher than it
would be otherwise now there's a trust
for one trust fund for airports and
Airways
another trust fund for highways and
transit another trust fund for port
maintenance and another trust fund for
inland waterways you probably don't even
know that right but we've got them all
and they're all bad they're all in
trouble so the flaws this model is
inherently mean it sounds kind of mark
no user taxes trust fund to protect the
money this is how we built the
interstate highways but what it's become
from politics over the years is just a
mess first of all these user taxes are
not like your electric bill which goes
to the electric company directly and
they use it to fund bonds for big for
new power plants and stuff no this is
there still taxes because their taxes
Congress is very reluctant to increase
the rates when there's a genuine need
for more investment it's a tax increase
people don't distinguish that it's a
user tax and it only goes for that so
that makes it hard we have a chronic
problem of not enough good investment
going on there's awful lot of
redistribution because this is all done
by political things redistribution from
users who pay the user taxes to
non-users like transit riders of a third
of your gas taxes federal gas taxes go
for non highway purposes transit bike
paths all is kind of nonsense that's
politically attractive to members of
Congress it distorts investment because
the decisions that are made with a lot
of this money are made by people what's
what's politically most advantageous not
what's produces the best return on
investment so we have a lot of distorted
investment in infrastructure when we
that's exactly what we don't need we
need to put it all to the highest and
best use we have as I mentioned the
large added costs one dollar of federal
money means you have to comply with the
davis-bacon act and pay union prevailing
wages to buy America Act all kinds of
minority and women business set-asides
and so forth so it increases the cost by
anywhere between ten and twenty percent
of your total project if there's any
federal money and you have to have all
those things there's no pricing and all
these things no pricing and air traffic
control no pricing on highways except
for a few toll roads no pricing on the
waterways no pricing in the harbors so
you have congestion you have missed a
location again and really important
point all this capital investment that
it has done by federal and state user
tax money
is all cash basis investing it's not
finance and the way you do when you when
you take out a mortgage to acquire your
house or when a business issues revenue
bonds like electric utility does to buy
up to build a new power plant and then
it's paid for overtime as people enjoy
the benefits of it and pay their bills
that's not the model we use in all this
this is all an extremely distorted model
for how to do this stuff so our
challenge and in this report and all the
stuff that we're doing is to rethink
this model that's been used for 5060
years and first premise is we've gotta
sort out what's truly should be the
federal government have a system of
federal state and local governments what
uniquely should the federal role be in
this and what's properly the state and
local government decision-making well
not necessarily providing but making the
decisions and deciding what things get
done and what things don't second
principle is to shift from user taxes to
user fees where it's like a utility bill
you pay it to the provider of the
infrastructure and then they can
leverage that they can raise the issue
bonds and so forth that are paid to do
the investments shift as I said then
from funding to financing for the large
projects and then funding the financing
sounds just like a word change but if
you have to finance it you have to go to
the capital markets and you have to meet
a market theft is this really a sound
what's the likelihood that the people
who put up the money you're going to get
paid back there has to be a sort of a
pretty reliable funding mechanism built
in there generally from user payments
you totally built high payments in order
for the project that could find finance
and if it can't it's probably not a
project that we should be investing in
in the first place and this is radically
different from what it's done in all
these areas today for the most part and
there's a big opportunity to expand the
private sectors role because revenue
bonding and and a reliable stream of
user payments lends itself very much to
the long-term public-private
partnerships there you can bring in a
true market player to run infrastructure
of big infrastructure assets as
businesses
so let's just quickly take a look at a
few of these areas of all these areas
that do get federal money airports are
the most market-based of the group first
of all they have they charge their
customers airlines pay landing fees and
they pay space rentals and that's a big
sort that's the main source of airport
revenue passengers at most airports pay
a passage facility charge between three
dollars and four dollars and fifty cents
per per trip for one-way trip and those
are those are bondable against and the
airports do bond against them to issue
Airport revenue bonds and this is a very
much like a business would do federal
grants are actually a small part of the
budget for large airports and medium
airports which together handle about 85
to 90 percent of all the passenger
volume the small airports are much more
dependent on federal grants but for the
vast majority of us travelers these
airports could be completely self square
the federal grants could become
irrelevant so our proposal is that we
end all we end federal grants for all
passenger airports including the small
ones because they would just need to
charge higher passenger facility charges
and maybe make their landing fees a
little more realistic remove the limits
that the federal government Congress
imposes limits at the behest of the
airlines on the passenger facility fees
but the trade-off would be you can lower
the the ticket tax on the one side and
on the other side let the airports
self-fund them it's a it's a and I
managed to sell this to Grover Norquist
as a devolution of the federal shrinking
the federal role and this is a sea
change because Grover Norquist's and his
organization at NTU have historically
always bought into the airport airline
the airline's propaganda line that the
federal limit on the passenger facility
charge is actually protecting the people
from a federal tax increase it's
completely backwards but Congress always
falls for that so that we may we may
change at this time and remove the
limits on airport privatization air
traffic control you know I've given
talks on that a reason weekend this is
another thing that it is largely the
dollars coming in in your ticket taxes
pay for most of the costs of running the
air traffic control system but this is
such a mess
of a big bureaucracy that's trying to
run a high-tech service business and is
just very poorly suited to the task so
we need and our proposal which we've
been making in various forums for over
20 years is to separate the air traffic
control operation from the faa faa
should be a safety just a safety
regulator of aviation that's a big
enough job for it to do a shift to
direct user fees for for aircraft
control which would enable the spun off
preferably nonprofit corporation to
issue revenue bonds to pay for the 20
billion dollar modernization that
they're trying to do now out of annual
operating cash flow appropriated by
Congress with Congress making a lot of
priorities is on what they should spend
it on have arms like safety regulations
so forth highways up as I mentioned the
Highway Trust Fund was originally set up
as a pretty good user financing user
funding mechanism for building the
interstate highway system but once it
was the original plan was largely built
out Congress all we had this great
revenue stream what else can we do it
well we can give them grants for their
state highways we can give them grants
for transit that happened under Ronald
Reagan by the way the opening it up for
transit funding so today hundred percent
of money the federal highway gas taxes
comes from automobiles and trucks but
only seventy percent of it actually is
spent on highways the other thirty
percent is all these other non Highway
Transportation stuff mostly urban
transit so we propose rethink the
federal role make it the interstate
routes only which is the actual
interstate highways and some of the
others that are called national highway
system that many of them should be
upgraded to interstates remove the
federal restrictions that are imposed on
states that prevent them from using
tolling so give the state's tools to
cope with the bigger responsibilities of
being responsible for all the rest of
the highway system and and build up
support for the concept of highways as a
network utility that's paid for directly
by their users so for transit what
happens to transit then if the Federals
are feds are no longer providing well
the situation with transit is that a
hundred percent you know when people
ride washington metro and you know buy
their tickets and so forth a hundred
percent of the capital costs of building
transit systems buying by
is is paid for by subsidies by federal
subsidies state subsidies and local
subsidies the farebox pays for anywhere
from ten percent to maybe fifty percent
of the operating costs just the
operating costs of a transit system it's
true cross the United States and so and
also getting free federal money if you
want to build capital projects means
that it biases the decision away from
inexpensive things like better bus
systems and toward capital intensive
things if the feds will pay for half of
the cost of a new light rail line
wouldn't you rather have a light rail
line even if it doesn't make any
economic sense it's glitzy you can cut a
ribbon on it you say we're a modern
we're a world-class City now because we
have a light rail line so it biases
decisions in all the wrong ways against
what's cost effective so our solution
evolved it to urban governments say look
sink or swim guys that will mean they
will reduce costs by switching mostly to
bus rapid transit instead of rail they
will contract out service their places
that do it now save thirty to
thirty-five percent on the cost of
running bus routes and increase revenues
they could charge market rates based
fares on all these nice subway systems
and the light rail of people who use a
few people who use them charge market
base rate except for poor people and
give them transfer foul chures and you
could probably double the revenue of a
transit system by doing that so reduce
the cost increase revenues ports this is
you probably have never heard of any of
this but we have this thing called the
harbor maintenance tax it's a user tax
that every every cargo ship that's
unloaded on us port coming from abroad
pays a percentage of the value of the
cargo know why that who knows but the
that goes into the harbor maintenance
trust fund an account in the federal
government that is for hot for harbor
dredging and and the ports put in
requests and the Army Corps of Engineers
has to do big study and Congress every
year will appropriates money but the
amount they appropriate every year is
only about half of what comes in in the
harbor maintenance tax because OMB likes
to hoard that money so that it makes the
federal budget deficit look smaller this
used to happen with
yes and Trust Fund and of the highway
and that Congress got rid of that
eventually but it still happens with
Harbor but the biggest flaw is that
ports all compete with one another all
the West Coast ports compete with one
another the West Coast ports compete
with the Gulf and the East Coast ports
so why should the federal government be
picking winners and losers and why
should the ports that have naturally
deep harbors like Oakland Los Angeles
Seattle Norfolk that don't need dredging
or need very little be paying money for
harbor dredging to help their
competitors and yet they do it because
that's the system as they all figure
well we better we're better off together
in the American Association of Port
Authority's all singing from the same
hymn book than to maybe have some ports
have to go out of business because they
just aren't competitive so our proposal
is to abolish the harbor maintenance tax
and the harbor maintenance trust fund
because ports can naturally self-fund
port of miami is actually doing that now
so they can dredge the 50 feet to meet
the larger ships because they're not
sure they're going to get their federal
money and if they wait it may be 10
years until they get it so they're
issuing bonds and doing it themselves
finally inland waterways you know he has
whole huge network you know on the
Mississippi River the Ohio River and so
forth barge operators pay a user tax on
diesel fuel goes into a trust fund for
maintaining and improving the inland
waterway system user tax only covers
eight percent of the total cost of
operating and maintaining and improving
the waterways the main biggest thing is
what expense the other is that locks and
dams are mostly obsolete and they're not
big enough they're in poor shape and so
forth and again Congress doesn't
appropriate enough money because both of
it has to come out of the general fund
and that is just clearly gone you know
going to be gone very soon we're not
going to have it so our proposal and
this is actually this has actually been
suggested in a report the Army Corps of
Engineers has a little research
institute and they've sort of looked at
the future of this about a year ago and
said well there may we may have to
really change the model here and one of
the alternatives could be to have
individual waterways developed in some
kind of a user pay mekkin
nism that would pay for at least mode
they say most we say all of the costs of
rebuilding the locks and dams and so
forth and and Havelock fees as a
bondable revenue stream but do it
corridor by corridor and each one B
could be kind of a self-governing thing
and there's actually a little bit of
traction for that idea now because
people can the smarter ones that can
look further ahead can see the
handwriting on the wall and say this
this system is not going to be
sustainable in the way we've had it for
the past 40 or 50 years so now one thing
also public-private partnerships you
know we've seen this reason has played a
big role in introducing long-term ppps
for highway projects such as the Capital
Beltway if you've been to Washington
recently they just opened in the fall
this finally express toll lanes on a
major portion of the Capital Beltway
around Washington DC it's a huge huge
improvement it's done by a 70-year toll
concession entirely at risk by the
private sector if if neither of people
use them and not willing to pay the
rates that they need to do the variable
toll rates to keep traffic flowing at 50
60 miles an hour then they're at risk
and there's no taxpayer the taxpayers
are not at risk in this so there's a
whole lot of things we can do with this
model applied not only highways express
lane networks airport terminals
LaGuardia Airport there they're planning
to do this for the new Central Terminal
the RFP is going to be out in a few
months we can pay for air traffic
control modernization this way dredging
harbors and channels new terminals at
ports there's a lot of opportunities for
using this model it's very well-suited
once you have financing and once you
have true user fees in place now some
people can say well the government can
do all this airports are ready efforts
are all government-owned they're already
doing this that's true so what value
does and we have toll road agencies in
many states that about a third of the
states have toward what is the private
sector add to what you could do with a
government authority well risk transfer
is a big one because taxpayers are
ultimately backstopping the government
airport authorities and toll agencies in
the long-term properly structured PPP
only the investors are at risk for that
and that's a big difference megaprojects
you know billion dollar scale projects
have a very bad track record you the big
dig in Boston anybody remember of big
cost overruns late completion /
optimistic forecasts of how many people
are using how much we will pay for it
and so forth so risk scratcher is a huge
advantage of ppps guaranteed long-term
maintenance the people who finance these
projects the first thing they look at is
because you're expecting to attract
people to pay user fees is it going to
be is there a guarantee that it's going
to be properly maintained for the entire
lifetime of the thing and so that is
that is true in these kinds of
arrangements so you have to guarantee
you have to prove to the investors that
they'll be properly maintained for the
entire period out of the user fee
revenues in order to get the money in
the first place now the additional
investment we have globally over the
last decade there's infrastructure
investment funds that have amassed over
200 billion dollars to invest in
infrastructure and not just in the u.s.
worldwide but electric utilities
transmission lines water systems but
also airports toll roads and so forth so
there's a lot of capital so it's a new
source and not just debt the public
sector does things with when they do
these these things they do it 100% debt
we have a new source that can equity
typically is twenty to twenty-five
percent of the of the capital costs of
these projects and so that's a whole new
jump-starting of more investment but we
sound investment because you have all
the safeguards for selecting what kind
of projects to do and innovation I don't
have time to give you a lot of examples
but we've already seen in the toll road
area big invest big innovations that the
private sector has come up with that
state do tease had not thought of would
have seen as too risky if they had
thought of them too much risk of
political bite biting them in the back
for taking a risk so forth so what we
are doing is to wrap up we first of all
last month issued this policy study
which is aimed primarily at the fiscal
conservatives in Congress to open their
eyes to a different way of doing things
and
are planning to give briefings and
Republican Study Committee and groups
like that it's gotten a lot of play
already in the transportation news media
we have a major project that's underway
that I mentioned at last year's reason
weekend that we're making progress on to
develop a political coalition in favor
of an air traffic control corporation
we're working with the main trade
association for airports the airport
council international on a deef everal
ization plan whereby the airports at
least the large and medium ones are
willing to give up their Airport grants
the federal grants in exchange for the
ability to self-fund with a with a
higher basically unlimited passenger
facility charge whatever whatever it
needs to be to replace the federal
grants we have we've worked with during
last year's highway bill reauthorization
and we're continuing to work with a
tolling coalition that wants to remove
the federal ban on using tolls on the
interstate system not to put a toll
booth on existing unimproved things but
rather to finance the rebuilding and
modernization as the interstate system
is where interstates are over the next
20 years most of them almost all of them
that were built in the in the 60s and
70s will exceed their 50-year original
design life most of them are obsolete in
terms of design they don't have enough
lanes they have bottleneck interchanges
it's a massive project and we have a big
study underway on that and we're working
with the interstate tolling coalition
and the toll roads trade association on
that our newest analyst baruch
Feigenbaum is working on some
interesting things on rethinking you
knows fresh ideas on urban transit we're
working with Sam Staley former reason
member team member now at Florida State
University who's getting Believe It or
Not Rockefeller fund grants for outside
the box thinking on urban transit and so
we're doing some neat things there and
we're increasingly critiquing the status
quo on ports and waterways and and
because those things are up for
reauthorization this year in Congress
and we're going to try to make a big
thing out of that so wrap up our message
to the transportation world and to
policymakers the old era that we've
known for 50 years of federal user tat
user taxes and trust funds is dying it's
not cannot be sustained in the era that
we're now
entered of downsizing the federal
government and getting its fiscal house
in order we need to shrink the federal
role and that means the states are going
to need to do more be responsible for
more and so user taxes will need to be
phased out and user fees direct user
fees phased in and we're going to be
pushing hard across the board in all of
these areas for the principles of true
user fees that are paid to the operator
not to the government for financing
projects going to the capital markets
and and having to meet a market test for
deciding which investments in ports
which investments in waterways which
investments in highways actually make
sense and are sustainable and that means
of course then expanding the role of PPP
concessions and with that I think I've
Amy I've met your target for 15 minutes
for questions thank you